Tropical forests are one of the world's
most important carbon sinks,
absorbing over one fifth of the emissions
from burning fossil fuels every year.
The latest research suggests
that without them
the world would already be
nearly one degree Celsius hotter.
We can't solve climate change
without tropical forests.
But right now,
instead of protecting forests,
we're cutting them down.
Already, about one sixth
of the Amazon has been lost,
and some scientists fear
that we're nearing a tipping point
that could mean loss of the entire forest.
Forests in Indonesia and Malaysia,
even the vast forests of Central Africa,
are under threat as well.
And deforestation means carbon pollution.
In fact, tropical deforestation worldwide
accounts for almost as much emissions
as all the world's cars
and trucks combined.
So losing tropical forests
means losing any hope
of limiting the rise
in global temperatures
to 1.5 or even two degrees Celsius.
The heart of the problem is economic.
As long as it's profitable
to chop down forests for timber
or clear them for agriculture,
we'll continue to lose them.
Now, I'm not suggesting that we try
to halt capitalism in its tracks.
We need to fix the market, not abandon it.
We need a new and better economic
development model
for tropical forest countries.
And that means changing the incentives
so that forests are worth
more alive than dead.
If we can do that,
we will drive investment
into tropical forest protection
while also producing the goods
and services we need.
This is the Amazon forest in Mato Grosso,
a Brazilian state that's as large as Texas
and a chunk of California combined,
and one of the world's largest
producers of beef and soy.
Mato Grosso is now a model
of economic development
and forest protection.
But back in 2004,
Mato Grosso was one of the world's
largest carbon polluters
entirely because
of tropical deforestation.
Since then, deforestation
is down over 85 percent.
How?
Well, Mato Grosso didn't reduce
emissions by shutting down agriculture.
Instead, with support from the governments
of Germany and Norway,
it stepped up enforcement
against illegal land grabbers.
It empowered local communities
and indigenous populations
to protect their territories.
It worked with agricultural producers
and traders across the supply chain
to invest in new and more sustainable
production methods.
These efforts were supported
by a broad array of NGOs and businesses
and Indigenous organizations.
And they worked so well
that when a new governor
was elected in 2018,
he immediately affirmed his commitment
to reducing deforestation
and continued the state’s policies.
Because he saw how these new policies
were attracting new investment
and laying the foundation
for sustainable growth.
If we're going to stave off
climate catastrophe,
the world needs many more Mato Grossos.
Now, Mato Grosso began
its bold experiment with public funding.
But if we're going to preserve
and extend those gains
and scale them up to jurisdictions
around the world,
we need a new and more durable
and much larger source of forest finance.
And the key to unlocking that finance?
Making forests worth more alive than dead.
That means putting a value
on standing forests
in a way that channels new investment,
hard cash, into sustainable green growth
that protects the forests
while supporting the livelihoods
of people who live there.
It's a development model
that could make Brazil and Indonesia
and other forest nations
the world’s first
green economic superpowers,
that allows them to capture the full value
of their natural resources.
This is the goal of the LEAF Coalition.
LEAF stands for Lowering Emissions
by Accelerating Forest finance.
It's a coalition of 12 companies
and three countries
that has committed
one billion dollars in finance
for forest protection at scale
over the next five years,
one of the largest-ever public-private
investments in forest protection.
That first billion dollars
will pay for 100 million tons
of emissions reductions,
with the prospect of many
more billions to come.
I have a special connection to this story
because the idea that became LEAF
was drawn up on a whiteboard
in my old office
at Environmental Defense Fund
over eight years ago.
Now, if I had been giving this talk then,
it would have been purely theoretical.
But that was before
the full success of Mato Grosso
and before the key building blocks
that made LEAF possible
were put into place.
These three building blocks
are essential to any credible market.
Accurate measurement,
a standard for quality
and a platform for transactions.
First, credible forest transactions
require accurate and precise measurement,
and thanks to advances in satellite
data and remote sensing,
we can measure the amount
of carbon a forest contains
and track changes in real time.
The second building block
is a standard for quality
so that buyers of emissions reductions
can be certain they're getting
the real thing.
At LEAF we use a new approach
that focuses on the performance
not of individual forests,
but of entire official jurisdictions,
like a state or nation.
It builds in buffers
against risks like forest fire,
and it requires countries, forest nations,
to increase their ambition over time.
The third and final building block
is a platform for transactions.
We created a financial
intermediary called Emergent
that connects sellers,
forest nations that have emissions
reductions that they can sell,
with buyers who include companies
that are looking to make good
on their voluntary climate commitments.
You put those three
building blocks together
and you get a reliable and robust
market for forest carbon
that enables economies to thrive
while protecting the forest.
We know it's possible.
In Mato Grosso,
soy production more than doubled
and cattle increased by over a quarter,
even as deforestation plummeted.
So the LEAF model promises
better outcomes for forests,
better outcomes for the people
who live there
and better outcomes
for the forest nations as a whole.
But you may be asking,
what's in it for the companies?
Well, now more than ever,
companies see a business case
for climate action.
Their customers are demanding it,
their investors are,
so are their employees.
And companies recognize
that truly leading on climate
means doing two things.
First, reducing emissions in their own
operations and supply chains.
And the companies that are part of LEAF
have all been required to set
science-based targets
for their own emissions.
Second, they must contribute
to the broader fight.
And one of the most important ways
that these companies,
or any company,
can help solve climate change
outside their own operations
and supply chains
is by protecting tropical forests.
So that bears repeating.
Companies in LEAF
are investing in forest protection
over and above what they're doing
to reduce their own emissions.
It's not a substitute,
it's a supplement.
Because if we're going
to solve climate change,
we need to achieve both
deep cuts in fossil fuel emissions
and dramatic reductions
in forest emissions.
It took over a decade to put all
of the building blocks in place
that made LEAF possible.
And the results so far
are enormously encouraging.
In the next ten years,
if we can expand LEAF globally,
we can stop tropical deforestation,
protect some of the largest
carbon sinks on the planet,
and enable forest nations and local
populations to thrive and grow.
All because we harness
the power of the market
to reflect the full value
of standing forests
and make them worth more alive than dead.
Thank you.
(Applause)